Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. We're doing another bonus episode this week on terrorism in the aftermath of the New Zealand mosque attacks. We'll be exploring what psychological factors cause a person to commit heinous acts of mass violence, technology's role in spreading extremist propaganda, and what governments and communities can do to prevent acts of terrorism. Our guest is Dr. Ari Krooglansky, an APA fellow and distinguished university professor in psychology at the University of Maryland.
欢迎收听美国心理学会（APA）的播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本周我们制作了另一期特别节目，探讨新西兰清真寺袭击事件后的恐怖主义问题。我们将探讨导致个人犯下大规模暴力罪行的心理因素、科技在传播极端主义宣传中的作用，以及政府和社区可以采取哪些措施来预防恐怖主义行为。我们的嘉宾是阿里·克鲁格兰斯基（Dr. Ari Kruglanski）博士，他是美国心理学会会士，也是马里兰大学心理学杰出教授。
He's an expert on terrorism, radicalization, and de-radicalization. Welcome, Dr. Kuglansky. Good to be here, Kately. I first want to start off with New Zealand. These attacks were clearly designed to go viral because the suspect wore a camera on his head to live streaming on Facebook. And since that time, the video is spread across countless social media platforms, despite on efforts to delete copies. How have the internet and social media change the dynamics of terrorist groups or lone actor terrorists? I think it provided a much wider audience that was ever possible. You know, a very famous terrorism expert, Brian Jenkins, once quipped that terrorists want a lot of people watching, not a lot of people dead, because they want the impact of the publicity,
他是恐怖主义、激进化和去激进化方面的专家。欢迎您，克鲁格兰斯基博士。很高兴来到这里，凯特琳。我想先从新西兰事件谈起。这些袭击显然是为了在网上疯传而设计的，因为嫌疑人戴着摄像头并在Facebook上进行了直播。自那时起，尽管人们努力删除副本，但视频还是在无数社交媒体平台上流传开来。互联网和社交媒体如何改变了恐怖组织或“独狼”恐怖分子的动态？我认为它提供了比以往任何时候都更广泛的受众。你知道，一位非常著名的恐怖主义专家布莱恩·詹金斯（Brian Jenkins）曾打趣说，恐怖分子希望有很多人观看，而不是很多人死亡，因为他们想要的是宣传带来的影响，
significance that it accords them. And the social media, the internet technology, allows the publics that watches them, the audiences to be multiplied by millionfold as compared to what was once possible. So in that sense, it becomes a much more appealing stage, a much more appealing platform for people who are trying to get attention,
以及这种宣传赋予他们的重要性。社交媒体和互联网技术使观看他们的公众和受众比以往任何时候都增加了数百万倍。因此，从这个意义上说，对于那些试图通过暴力和手段来博取关注、
get notoriety, get significance through violence and man. And do you think by spreading it on social media and the internet, do you think that can encourage others? Because that seemed to be a goal of the suspect was to encourage others to commit acts of violence. It definitely can. I mean, the whole thing about mass shootings is that it's a very much an emulated, a copycatting phenomenon.
获得恶名、获得重要性的人来说，这成了一个更具吸引力的舞台，一个更具吸引力的平台。你认为通过在社交媒体和互联网上传播这些内容，会鼓励其他人效仿吗？因为嫌疑人的目标似乎就是鼓励他人实施暴力行为。绝对会。我的意思是，大规模枪击事件的本质就是一种非常典型的模仿现象。
What is particularly troubling for me is that it's spread from school shootings by disgruntled stories. students all the way to New Zealand and other places where people use it for ideological purposes, ostensibly. And anybody who has the cause and has the motivation to get notoriety is now aware that this is a very efficient tool that's going to be watched by millions, if not billions of people. And do you think there's some contagion element to this? I know that's a very debated topic about if there is a contagion of a variety of things. But do you think in this instance
令我特别不安的是，这种现象已经从心怀不满的学生制造的校园枪击案，蔓延到了新西兰和其他地方，人们表面上将其用于意识形态目的。任何有动机并渴望获得恶名的人现在都知道，这是一个非常有效的工具，会被数百万人甚至数十亿人观看。你认为这其中存在某种传染因素吗？我知道关于各种事物是否存在传染性是一个非常有争议的话题。但你认为在这种情况下
that it could be? I would assume. I would assume that it's definitely increasing in frequency, both in the United States and now we have New Zealand. These acts of violence that are widely publicized in the media, whether it's a vehicular murder or shootings of different kinds, These things are multiplying. And I think that it's definitely copycating, not just simply copycading, but realizing that it's a very effective way of getting attention to oneself, getting attention to one's cause, getting attentions to one's heroism, as it were. So I would not be surprised that it would be multiplying even more in the future. New Zealand's prime minister has vowed not to speak the name of the alleged attacker, which is something that a lot of people have praised her for.
它可能存在吗？我想是的。我认为这种行为的频率绝对在增加，无论是在美国，还是现在的新西兰。这些在媒体上被广泛宣传的暴力行为，无论是驾车撞人还是各种枪击事件，都在成倍增加。我认为这绝对是模仿，不仅仅是简单的模仿，而是意识到这是一种引起他人关注、引起对自身事业的关注、引起对所谓“英雄主义”关注的非常有效的方式。所以我不会对未来这种行为进一步增加感到惊讶。新西兰总理誓言不提及嫌疑人的名字，许多人对此表示赞赏。
Do you think this will help deter others, given the drive that we spoke of, of many terrorists looking for infamy? Do you think that will have any impact? I think it's a very valuable gesture that she did, because ultimately the motivation underlying the deed is, to my mind, the search for notoriety and significance, doing something that gains their respect and admiration of millions of people. So not mentioning the name takes chips away at that motivation.
考虑到我们刚才谈到的许多恐怖分子寻求恶名的驱动力，你认为这会有助于威慑其他人吗？你认为这会有任何影响吗？我认为她所做的姿态非常有价值，因为归根结底，我认为驱动这种行为的动机是寻求恶名和重要性，通过做某事来获得数百万人的尊重和钦佩。所以不提及名字会削弱这种动机。
To what extent this will be enough is to be doubted because, you know, the media will have to share in keeping the name secret and others will catch the video. and publicize it. So, you know, whereas symbolically it's a very important gesture that she did, I'm not sure that ultimately it will have all that much of an impact. And what is your research shown about white supremacists? Are they different from other kinds of terrorists you've studied? The basic, the core dynamics is the same. In both cases of the white suprematist or the Islamic terrorist or the Sri Lankan terrorists, that we studied,
这种做法能在多大程度上奏效还值得怀疑，因为媒体必须共同努力对名字保密，而其他人也会获取视频并进行宣传。所以，虽然她所做的在象征意义上非常重要，但我并不确定它最终会产生多大的影响。你的研究对白人至上主义者有什么发现？他们和你研究过的其他类型的恐怖分子有什么不同吗？基本的、核心的动态是一样的。无论是白人至上主义者、伊斯兰恐怖分子还是我们研究过的斯里兰卡恐怖分子，
the underlying motivation is what we call the quest for significance, the quest to matter, to have self-respect and respect of others. This is very much the case with white suprematist.
其潜在动机都是我们所说的“对重要性的追求”，即追求被重视、获得自尊以及他人的尊重。白人至上主义者的情况也是如此。
We just finished a book on neo-Nazis in Germany to be published by Oxford University Press and we studied about 40 of them that went through the whole cycle of joining,
我们刚刚完成了一本关于德国新纳粹分子的书，即将由牛津大学出版社出版。我们研究了大约40名经历了从加入、
being active for about 10 years, living and then trying to reintegrate into society. And the motivations are very similar to those of the youngsters who travel to Syria or Iraq to join the ranks of ISIS. The motivation is to do something important, to matter, to become a hero, a martyr, to gain power, to gain influence through violence against others. We have a model that explains the conjunction of this motivation with an ideological narrative and the support of a network that validates the narrative. When you have these three components together, whether it be white suprematist, Islamic jihadists or a national, ethno-national terrorists, you have the very same ingredients.
活跃约10年、生活，然后试图重新融入社会整个周期的成员。他们的动机与那些前往叙利亚或伊拉克加入ISIS行列的年轻人非常相似。动机都是为了做一些重要的事情，为了被重视，为了成为英雄、烈士，为了通过对他人的暴力获得权力和影响力。我们有一个模型，解释了这种动机与意识形态叙事以及验证该叙事的网络支持之间的结合。当你把这三个要素结合在一起时，无论是白人至上主义者、伊斯兰圣战分子还是民族/族裔民族主义恐怖分子，你得到的成分都是一样的。
There is the need to become significant, to do something heroic, to become a martyr, a narrative that tells you how to do it, how to attain that goal, through hitting, through fighting, through destroying the alleged enemy of one's religion, one's nation, one's ethnic group. And there is a group and network that supports that narrative, that validates the narrative, that views it as a group. part of shared reality, that this is real, that this is really justifiable, even though mayhem and violence are generally prohibited in society, you need a network that, a local network that tells you, no, no, in this case, it's allowable. You have permission. You have the, you know, the license to kill, as it were. This sounds like the book you have coming out this June called the three pillars of radicalization, and in those pillars you mentioned or need narratives and network.
那就是成为重要人物的需要，做英雄事迹的需要，成为烈士的需要；一套告诉你如何做到这一点、如何通过打击、战斗、摧毁你所属宗教、民族或族裔的所谓敌人来实现这一目标的叙事；以及一个支持该叙事、验证该叙事、将其视为共享现实的一部分的网络。即使在社会中通常禁止混乱和暴力，你也需要一个本地网络告诉你：“不，不，在这种情况下，这是允许的。”你拥有了所谓的“杀人执照”。这听起来像是你今年6月即将出版的书《激进化的三大支柱》，在这些支柱中，你提到了需求、叙事和网络。
Can you explain those concepts a little bit more? I know we just touched on the network element of it, but the other two, the needs and the narratives. Again, the need, you know, in the literature on terrorism, there is usually a list of motivations that people mention. Adoration of the leader, loyalty to the leader, religious motivations, the perks of paradise, money, even feminism to show that women can also do. it, but we find that underlying all these specific motivations, there is a universal human need to be noticed, to be respected, to have significance. And so how do you, it's a universal need. Most people have it to some degree.
你能多解释一下这些概念吗？我知道我们刚才谈到了网络要素，但另外两个，即需求和叙事呢？再说一次，关于需求，在恐怖主义文献中，通常有一系列人们提到的动机。崇拜领袖、对领袖的忠诚、宗教动机、天堂的福利、金钱，甚至是女权主义，以证明女性也能做到。但我们发现，在所有这些具体动机的背后，存在一种普遍的人类需求，即被注意到、被尊重、拥有重要性。那么，这是一个普遍的需求。大多数人都有某种程度的需求。
Some people are more ambitious in that regard. Others less ambitious. But everybody wants to be noticed, wants to matter. Most people attain it through socially acceptable means. You and I are trying to make our way through our contributions to society, through our profession, through prosocial deeds that are compatible with societal requirements. But you can also gain significance through fighting the alleged enemies of your group. And fighting in violence is particularly appealing to young people.
有些人在这方面更有野心，有些人则没那么有野心。但每个人都想被注意到，想被重视。大多数人通过社会可接受的方式来实现这一点。你和我正试图通过我们对社会的贡献、通过我们的职业、通过符合社会要求的亲社会行为来走出自己的路。但你也可以通过打击你所在群体的所谓敌人来获得重要性。而通过暴力进行战斗对年轻人尤其具有吸引力。
It's a universal, primordial means of gaining significance. That's how animals gain significance. That's how little children resolve their conflict. That's how sophisticated nations gain their place in the international pecking order by having a nuclear arsenal that can unleash untold violence. So, you know, there is something about violence that is very appealing as a tool to significance. A narrative that suggests, you know, you can become a hero overnight. You can become a martyr by attacking your enemies, whoever they might be, can be very appealing.
这是一种普遍的、原始的获得重要性的手段。动物就是这样获得重要性的。小孩子也是这样解决冲突的。复杂的国家也是通过拥有能够释放巨大暴力的核武库来获得其在国际等级制度中的地位。所以，暴力作为一种获得重要性的工具确实非常有吸引力。一种暗示你可以一夜之间成为英雄、通过攻击敌人（无论他们是谁）成为烈士的叙事，可能非常有吸引力。
So this is the narrative aspect that tells you how to gain significance. And finally, because that narrative is usually at odds with the general societal narrative, narrative that prohibits violence against innocence, against women, children, the old folks, people who are innocent of any wrongdoing against you. You need a local group. It may be a neo-Nazi movement, it may be a white suprematist movement. It may be some imaginary movement of Knights Templar, as in the case of Andres Breivik, the Norwegian terrorist that killed about 70 people.
这就是叙事层面，它告诉你如何获得重要性。最后，因为这种叙事通常与一般社会叙事相冲突——即禁止对无辜者、妇女、儿童、老人以及对你没有任何不当行为的无辜者使用暴力的叙事——你需要一个本地群体。它可能是一个新纳粹运动，可能是一个白人至上主义运动，也可能是像挪威恐怖分子安德斯·布雷维克（Andres Breivik）那样，他杀害了大约70人，
in the island of Utoia. It can be, you know, the imagined audience on the internet that is going to applaud you. But you need this kind of permission from a group that you know is going to support you. So these are the three elements. They create a combustible, explosive mixture when they come together.
在乌托亚岛上，他所想象的圣殿骑士团。它也可以是互联网上为你鼓掌的想象中的受众。但你需要这种来自一个你知道会支持你的群体的许可。所以这就是这三个要素。当它们结合在一起时，会产生一种易燃的、爆炸性的混合物。
A person can be very vulnerable to radicalization and be often ready to embark on violence against innocence. In the case of the New Zealand suspect, he seemed to be radicalized by the internet only, based on what we're reading out in the news media, that he connected with others through the internet, spread their ideology together, and became motivated to commit acts of violence.
一个人可能非常容易受到激进化影响，并经常准备好对无辜者实施暴力。就新西兰嫌疑人而言，根据我们在新闻媒体上读到的内容，他似乎完全是通过互联网被激进化的，他通过互联网与他人联系，共同传播他们的意识形态，并产生了实施暴力行为的动机。
So can you explain how the internet has replaced groups of people physically getting together? Because today, if someone with any kind of view, extremist views can reach someone with the same views from any corner of the globe at any time of the day. So how does that change the dynamic? It's a very important aspect of the Internet technology. We mentioned the sheer size of the audience that a person, a mass shooter, terrorists can have by virtue of it being advertised on the Internet. But the aspect that you're mentioning now is also of great importance in that you can have a group, a chat room, a group of individuals who share your view almost on any topic at the Internet, whether it be killing, whether it be terrorism, whether it be pornography. And therefore, that removes to some extent the need to have a face-to-face group.
那么你能解释一下互联网是如何取代人们在物理空间上的聚集的吗？因为今天，任何持有极端观点的人都可以随时随地联系到全球任何角落持有相同观点的人。那么这如何改变了动态？这是互联网技术的一个非常重要的方面。我们提到了大规模枪击者或恐怖分子通过在互联网上宣传所能拥有的受众规模。但你现在提到的方面也非常重要，即你可以在互联网上拥有一个聊天室，一个在几乎任何话题上都持有相同观点的个人群体，无论是杀戮、恐怖主义还是色情。因此，这在一定程度上消除了面对面群体的需要。
You can always find a group of fans of like-minded people on the internet, and I think that allows people who are lone wolves who do not have any face-to-face connections with others who are similarly reminded, to get the kind of permission and support that the New Zealand shooter had. And I think that's a very dangerous aspect of the internet, that together with the sheer, volume of the audience makes this spectacular, if one can call them that, acts of violence and mayhem appealing to people who search for significance. One of the questions that arises after a terrorist attack is whether we can predict if someone will become a terrorist, because obviously there's many people who hold these extremist views
你总能在互联网上找到一群志同道合的粉丝，我认为这让那些没有与志同道合者进行面对面联系的“独狼”能够获得新西兰枪手所拥有的那种许可和支持。我认为这是互联网非常危险的一个方面，加上受众的庞大数量，使得这种壮观的（如果可以这样称呼的话）暴力和混乱行为对那些寻求重要性的人具有吸引力。恐怖袭击后出现的问题之一是，我们能否预测某人是否会成为恐怖分子，因为显然有许多人持有这些极端观点，
who do not become violent, like the New Zealand attacker. And there's some who do. So can we predict if someone will become a terrorist? becoming a terrorist is not a random event. One does not get up one morning and decides to shoot up people or blow oneself up. It's a psychological-driven event, which is influenced by the need, the narrative, and the network whose effect takes some time. If one knew what is the need of the individual, if one could measure it in advance, if one could see to what extent the individual. associates with a network of violently minded others.
但并没有变得暴力，不像新西兰袭击者那样。而有些人却会。那么我们能预测某人是否会成为恐怖分子吗？成为恐怖分子不是一个随机事件。一个人不会某天早上起床就决定去枪杀他人或炸死自己。这是一个心理驱动的事件，受到需求、叙事和网络的影响，其效果需要一些时间。如果一个人知道个人的需求是什么，如果能提前测量它，如果能看到个人在多大程度上与一个暴力倾向的群体联系在一起。
If one could know what the narrative is that the individual is partaking of, then one could predict it. So, you know, of course, very often we do not know these things about an individual, although those who are close to the person, his friends or her friends, relatives, the family, sometimes they know. a notice, a change of closing when it comes to Islamic terrorists, attendance, a more intensive attendance at religious meetings,
如果能知道个人参与的是什么叙事，那么就可以预测它。所以，当然，我们通常不知道关于个人的这些事情，尽管那些与该人亲近的人，他的朋友、亲戚、家人，有时他们知道。注意到变化，当涉及到伊斯兰恐怖分子时，出席率，更频繁地参加宗教会议，
a change in the individual's demeanor, a change in the individual's associations. These people who are in the immediate surroundings of the individual could be aware that there is a change and they should then
个人举止的变化，个人交往的变化。这些在个人周围的人可能会意识到发生了变化，他们应该
contact the authorities and share that information. So, yes, it could be predicted. In many cases, we don't have that information. In some cases, people have that information. And one way of combating and preventing these attacks would be to encourage people to, whenever such information becomes available, to share it with the authorities. Now, your question had another aspect, and that is, to what extent, individuals who hold extreme views and do not become terrorists or do not become shooters?
联系当局并分享这些信息。所以，是的，它是可以预测的。在许多情况下，我们没有这些信息。在某些情况下，人们有这些信息。打击和预防这些袭击的一种方法是鼓励人们在获得此类信息时，与当局分享。现在，你的问题还有另一个方面，那就是，持有极端观点但不成为恐怖分子或枪手的人在多大程度上……
You know, this issue of radicalization isn't a dichotomy. It is not either a radical or not a radical. It lies on a continuum. It's a matter of degree. And the question is, to what extent they need to be significant overshadows every. everything else and you're willing to sacrifice all, sacrifice your career, sacrifice your family, sacrifice your freedom, maybe sacrifice your life on the altar of that cause that lend your significance. So, you know, people may hold extreme views, but not be quite ready, not be quite
你知道，激进化这个问题不是一个二分法。它不是要么激进，要么不激进。它处于一个连续体上。这是一个程度问题。问题在于，他们对重要性的需求在多大程度上掩盖了一切。其他一切，你愿意牺牲一切，牺牲你的事业，牺牲你的家庭，牺牲你的自由，甚至牺牲你的生命在那个赋予你重要性的事业的祭坛上。所以，人们可能持有极端观点，但还没有完全准备好，没有完全
ready to give such dominance to this one needs that would override everything else. And this continuum goes all the way from, you know, supporting it attributinally to willing to contribute money, to participating in a minor role in terrorist organizations, all the way to the willingness to become a suicide bomber and sacrifice when lives on alter of the cause. It's a continuum. It's not a dichotomy. I mean, terrorism is a part of life in this 21st century. Do you have data to to show if the number of terrorists are increasing? No, I don't. But I think there are hundreds of terrorist groups operating.
准备好给予这种需求如此大的支配地位，以至于它会凌驾于一切之上。这个连续体一直延伸到，你知道，从归因上支持它，到愿意捐钱，到在恐怖组织中参与次要角色，一直到愿意成为自杀式炸弹袭击者并为事业牺牲生命。这是一个连续体。它不是二分法。我的意思是，恐怖主义是21世纪生活的一部分。你有数据表明恐怖分子的数量是否在增加吗？不，我没有。但我认为有数百个恐怖组织在运作。
I think the last number was around 300 that I've seen. And what seems to be increasing is the white suprematist groups that can become violent. You know, there is a polarization of societies, both in Europe and the United States. and there's legitimations of xenophobic attitudes and populist ideologies. And this become now the mainstream, whereas before they were kind of despised fringe in society. You see it in Germany. The Alternative of Germany is now in the Bundestag. You see it in France.
我想我看到的最后一个数字是300左右。而且看起来在增加的是可能变得暴力的白人至上主义团体。你知道，欧洲和美国社会都存在两极分化，仇外态度和民粹主义意识形态正在合法化。这现在成了主流，而以前它们在社会中是被鄙视的边缘群体。你在德国看到了这一点。德国选择党现在在联邦议院。你在法国看到了这一点。
You see it in Hungary. You see it in Poland. nationalism and populism are becoming more and more acceptable in society, and that in turn legitimizes the French groups that share the same ideas and are willing to go one step further through employment of violence. So I think the number of attacks have increased in the United States against synagogue, against mosques from in 2016-2016 onward. And you see the same tendencies the world over.
你在匈牙利看到了这一点。你在波兰看到了这一点。民族主义和民粹主义在社会中变得越来越被接受，这反过来又使那些持有相同想法并愿意通过使用暴力更进一步的边缘群体合法化。所以我认为，从2016年开始，美国针对犹太教堂、清真寺的袭击数量有所增加。你在世界各地也看到了同样的趋势。
Of course, not to speak about Islamic extremism that has been rampant in the last, you know, several decades and is not going away anytime soon. That's really one of the most pressing issues facing national security and international security today. It is indeed. It is indeed. And the danger is clear and present and of great proportions. I know that, you know, very esteemed colleague, Stephen Pinker, has been showing how the degree of violence have been declining over the centuries and including in the last century. But, you know, this is a kind of inductivist argument, the idea that because it has been decreasing, we can expect further decreases. And I do not think that this is the case. I think things can be reversed, and especially with the great technology, nuclear technology,
当然，更不用说过去几十年来猖獗且短期内不会消失的伊斯兰极端主义。这确实是当今国家安全和国际安全面临的最紧迫问题之一。确实如此。确实如此。危险是清晰可见的，而且规模巨大。我知道，非常受人尊敬的同事斯蒂芬·平克（Stephen Pinker）一直在展示暴力程度在几个世纪以来是如何下降的，包括在上个世纪。但是，这是一种归纳论证，即因为暴力一直在减少，我们就可以期待进一步减少。我不认为情况是这样。我认为事情是可以逆转的，特别是有了伟大的技术，核技术，
all kinds of weapons of mass destruction that could fall into the hands of fanatics. The danger is great, and society needs to mobilize itself to fight against it with all means at our disposal. Do you think there is enough international call to do so? I do not think so. I think especially in our country, there's been very little attention to the problem in its general form. We have been assuming that to fight terrorism, the only way is to employ them military and the police and do swore plots and so forth. But the problem is social psychological. You cannot kill an ideology.
各种可能落入狂热分子手中的大规模杀伤性武器。危险很大，社会需要动员起来，用我们所能使用的一切手段与之斗争。你认为是否有足够的国际呼吁来这样做吗？我不这么认为。我认为特别是在我们国家，对这种一般形式的问题关注很少。我们一直假设打击恐怖主义的唯一方法是动用军队和警察，粉碎阴谋等等。但这个问题是社会心理学的。你无法杀死一种意识形态。
Governor Romney quipped some years ago that we... We cannot kill our way out of this mess. Indeed we cannot. The military means are necessary but insufficient. You have to understand what prompts individuals to embark on violence and the embracement of radical ideologies. You have to prevent it. It has to be a whole society effort.
罗姆尼州长几年前打趣说，我们……我们无法通过杀戮来摆脱这种混乱。确实我们不能。军事手段是必要的，但还不够。你必须了解是什么促使个人走上暴力之路并拥抱激进意识形态。你必须预防它。这必须是全社会的努力。
It starts with the treatment of immigrants and refugees. It starts with respect. of alternative religions. It has to involve trusting the police, police community relations, community institutions, religious institutions, social services, the educational institutions. It has to be a whole society effort. It cannot be left to the military because the problem is not only resolvable on the military grounds. And you're often interviewed in the media about the topic of de-radicalization, and two recent stories were about, you were a part of, the stories highlighted recently reformed white supremacists.
它始于对移民和难民的对待。它始于对其他宗教的尊重。它必须涉及信任警察、警民关系、社区机构、宗教机构、社会服务、教育机构。这必须是全社会的努力。它不能留给军队，因为问题不仅仅可以在军事基础上解决。你经常在媒体上接受关于去激进化主题的采访，最近有两个故事是你参与的，故事重点介绍了最近改过自新的白人至上主义者。
Can you explain the process of how a person can become de-radicalized? There are many different forms of the radicalization. Basically, the radicalization is the reverse of radicalization. It involves the same three elements of need, narrative, and network. that I mentioned before. For example, in our work on the German neo-Nazis, those who left the movement, who became deradicalized, either had their alternative needs evoked.
你能解释一下一个人如何去激进化的过程吗？去激进化有许多不同的形式。基本上，去激进化是激进化的逆过程。它涉及我之前提到的需求、叙事和网络这三个要素。例如，在我们对德国新纳粹分子的研究中，那些离开该运动、变得去激进化的人，要么是他们的替代需求被唤起。
They became older, they wanted to get married, they wanted to have a profession. They got tired of just putting all their eggs in one basket. So that's the need component. some individuals became disenchanted with the ideology. They saw that ideology is just a kind of tokenism, that people are not serious about it, that the people in the movement are bent on partying
他们变老了，他们想结婚，他们想拥有一份职业。他们厌倦了把所有鸡蛋放在一个篮子里。所以这是需求部分。有些人对意识形态感到幻灭。他们看到意识形态只是一种象征主义，人们并不认真对待它，运动中的人一心只想聚会，
and getting into fights and brutality as opposed to really caring about the societal change that they were purported to care about. Some people were disenchanted with the network. They felt that this band of brothers that was promised them that gave them permission to become violent isn't really a band of brothers. There's a lot of knifing in the back, a lot of betrayal, lack of camaraderie. So, you know, all these are elements that can promote the radicalization. We have also seen the radicalization that is spontaneous.
参与打架和残暴行为，而不是真正关心他们声称关心的社会变革。有些人对网络感到幻灭。他们觉得承诺给他们的“兄弟连”——那个允许他们变得暴力的群体——并不是真正的兄弟连。背后捅刀子的情况很多，背叛很多，缺乏同志情谊。所以，所有这些都是可以促进去激进化的要素。我们也看到了自发的去激进化。
For example, in Egypt and Algeria, there were radical movements that deradicalized, as it were spontaneously. But it was not quite spontaneous. It happened when it became clear that the violence would not promote significance. When the public turns against al-jihad in Egypt, the al-jihad. organization because they were killing tourists and tourism is the lifeblood of Egyptian economy. So the public turns against them.
例如，在埃及和阿尔及利亚，有一些激进运动自发地去激进化了。但这并不完全是自发的。当暴力显然无法促进重要性时，它就发生了。当公众反对埃及的“圣战”组织时，因为他们杀害游客，而旅游业是埃及经济的命脉。所以公众反对他们。
Their weapons caches were confiscated, they were put in jail, and then they realized that the Koran prohibits violence. So, you know, once it is clear that violence is not going to serve the means of significance, they are open and their mind becomes open to. alternative ideas and they see that religion actually prohibits violence, something they did not see, strangely enough, when the going was strong. There are attempts to eradicate people in a systematic way, for example, in Saudi Arabia, in Sri Lanka, in detention camps where suspected and arrested terrorists are held.
他们的武器库被没收，他们被关进监狱，然后他们意识到《古兰经》禁止暴力。所以，一旦清楚暴力无法服务于重要性的手段，他们就开放了，他们的思想变得对替代思想开放，他们看到宗教实际上禁止暴力，奇怪的是，当他们势头强劲时，他们并没有看到这一点。有一些尝试以系统的方式去激进化人们，例如在沙特阿拉伯、斯里兰卡，在关押嫌疑和被捕恐怖分子的拘留营中。
And these attempts bring together the terrorists with governmental clerics that espouse a different interpretation of their religion. They offer them alternative ways of gaining significance through vocational training, through finding jobs, ways of integrating into society. So all of these have to do with addressing the need in a different way. extricating the person from the network that was supportive of violence and inserting them in the network that is anti-violence, sometimes their families, and exposing them to narratives that interpret religion or provide alternative ideologies as to what significance, how significance can be attained in ways other than violence. What can communities and governments do to prevent terrorism?
这些尝试将恐怖分子与宣扬不同宗教解释的政府教士聚集在一起。他们通过职业培训、通过寻找工作、通过融入社会的方式，为他们提供获得重要性的替代途径。所以所有这些都与以不同方式解决需求有关。将个人从支持暴力的网络中解脱出来，并将其插入一个反暴力的网络中，有时是他们的家庭，并让他们接触那些解释宗教或提供关于如何以暴力以外的方式获得重要性的替代意识形态的叙事。社区和政府可以做些什么来预防恐怖主义？
Can they step in and help give people significance that they were looking for through these extremist groups? Yes, that's definitely something that communities and governments can do. I'm collaborating with one such program in Denmark, the Arhus model, in the city of Arhus, who is run by my friend, Dr. Preben Bertelsen. and they use psychological principle to involve community institutions, the schools, the police in particular, social services, families to prevent radicalization whenever it rears its ugly head, whether it's youngsters in the school or even returning fighters from, the field of battle in Syria and Iraq.
他们能介入并帮助人们获得他们通过这些极端组织寻求的重要性吗？是的，这绝对是社区和政府可以做的事情。我正在与丹麦的一个此类项目合作，即奥胡斯模式（Arhus model），在奥胡斯市，由我的朋友普雷本·贝尔特尔森（Dr. Preben Bertelsen）博士负责。他们利用心理学原则，让社区机构、学校、警察（特别是警察）、社会服务机构、家庭参与进来，在激进化抬头时预防它，无论是学校里的年轻人，还是从叙利亚和伊拉克的战场上回来的战士。
It requires a concerted family effort. It requires trust between the police and the community so that the families feel that the police is on their side and is not going to just arrest and punish their members, but they will do all they can in order to mitigate attenuate their tendency to become radicals. So, you know, communities can do a lot. There is an attempt that has been criticized in many places,
这需要全家人的共同努力。这需要警察和社区之间的信任，这样家庭才会觉得警察站在他们这一边，不会仅仅逮捕和惩罚他们的成员，而是会尽其所能来减轻、减弱他们成为激进分子的倾向。所以，社区可以做很多事情。有一个在许多地方受到批评的尝试，
the strong cities network of which American cities, several American cities are also members, to promote this kind of community effort. It's not without its problems. Sometimes some communities feel targeted and victimized by these programs. need to keep searching for ways of addressing the problems as a society in its entirety. Psychologists can be very helpful because I think that we understand the roots of the problem.
即“强大城市网络”（Strong Cities Network），美国的一些城市也是其成员，旨在促进这种社区努力。它并非没有问题。有时一些社区觉得被这些项目针对和受害。需要不断寻找以整个社会来解决问题的方法。心理学家可以非常有帮助，因为我认为我们了解问题的根源。
We understand that it is the needs. It is the significance. It is the narratives. It is the networks. How to translate it into policies is beyond the meager power of a few psychologists. It has to be a whole community effort, a whole country effort, a governmental effort. It has to be a large initiative, long-lasting initiative. And of course, it's difficult to implement because, you know, politics is local and short-sighted. And what we are talking about is a long-term program that will last and extend itself for many years. Yeah, so for psychology's role in deregitalization, do you think, that psychologists are brought in enough on those elements, like working with governments,
我们了解是需求，是重要性，是叙事，是网络。如何将其转化为政策超出了少数心理学家的微薄力量。这必须是全社区的努力，全国家的努力，政府的努力。这必须是一个大型的、持久的倡议。当然，实施起来很困难，因为政治是地方性的和短视的。而我们谈论的是一个将持续并延伸多年的长期计划。是的，那么对于心理学在去激进化中的作用，你认为心理学家在这些要素上被引入得足够多吗，比如与政府合作，
working with communities? I do not think so. I think that both the psychological community, APA, APS, all kinds of organizations that bring together psychologists of various ills should offer their services to the government to a great extent, but also the government should realize that the problem is not going to away unless a large counter-radicalization effort is being made. And under the previous administration, President Obama, there was one attempt of a large meeting at the White House to promote counter-violent extremism initiatives. I think it kind of subsided at this point, but I think it is a dire need that needs to
与社区合作？我不这么认为。我认为心理学界、APA、APS以及所有汇集各种心理学家的组织都应该在很大程度上向政府提供服务，但政府也应该意识到，除非做出大规模的反激进化努力，否则问题不会消失。在前任奥巴马政府期间，曾有一次尝试在白宫举行大型会议，以促进反暴力极端主义倡议。我认为它在这一点上有点平息了，但我认为这是一个迫切的需要，需要
be undertaken, the initiatives have to be undertaken both on part of psychological societies and on part of governmental bodies that would realize that these kind of activities are necessary if we are to control and reduce that very dangerous phenomenon that we are seeing growing now. So there's still a lot of work to do, but do you feel like that? like there is hope in this area that we can stop the tide of terrorism and prevent more acts of violence and de-radicalize people? There is always hope. I think it's a very challenging problem, especially given the uncertainties that are sweeping the world these days, the migration crisis,
被承担起来，这些倡议必须由心理学会和政府机构共同承担，他们会意识到，如果我们想要控制和减少我们现在看到的这种非常危险的现象，这些活动是必要的。所以还有很多工作要做，但你觉得有希望吗？在这个领域有希望阻止恐怖主义的浪潮，预防更多的暴力行为并使人们去激进化吗？总是有希望的。我认为这是一个非常具有挑战性的问题，特别是考虑到这些天席卷世界的不确定性，移民危机，
the refugee crisis, economic issues, rising nationalism, you know, the European community, disintegrating or falling apart to some extent. These are very troubling phenomena that unsettled the kind of peacefulness and complacency that we have had since Second World War. And these uncertainties breed populism, breed simplistic ideologies
难民危机，经济问题，民族主义抬头，你知道，欧洲共同体在某种程度上正在瓦解或分崩离析。这些是非常令人不安的现象，扰乱了我们自第二次世界大战以来所拥有的那种和平与自满。这些不确定性滋生了民粹主义，滋生了简单的意识形态，
that speak in black and white terms that define us versus them and these ideologies dehumanize the out group and it's a very short step from those kind of perspectives to legitimation of violence.
用非黑即白的术语说话，定义“我们”与“他们”，这些意识形态将外群体非人化，从这些观点到暴力的合法化只有很短的一步。
So we're living in very troubling times but we need to do all that we can to assuage those dangerous possibilities and use the knowledge, psychological knowledge, social psychological knowledge that we have
所以我们生活在非常令人不安的时代，但我们需要尽我们所能来缓解这些危险的可能性，并利用我们拥有的知识、心理学知识、社会心理学知识，
in order to promote counter-radicalization activities wherever we can. Because otherwise, you know, we are drawing close to the edge of an abyss because these are very dangerous times and we must do what we can to resist those. alluring and yet extremely dangerous tendencies.
以便尽可能地促进反激进化活动。因为否则，我们正在接近深渊的边缘，因为这是非常危险的时代，我们必须尽我们所能来抵制那些诱人却极其危险的倾向。
Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Kruklansky. It's been a really fascinating conversation. Thank you very much, Kathleen. Dr. Kruklanski will be featured in the April issue of the Monitor on Psychology, APA's magazine for members that covers science, education, psychology practice, and more. The story will be posted online on April 1st. You can read it by visiting APA's website at APA.org slash monitor. This is the second bonus episode we've done focusing on
非常感谢您加入我们，克鲁格兰斯基博士。这是一次非常引人入胜的谈话。非常感谢，凯特琳。克鲁格兰斯基博士将出现在4月刊的《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）上，这是APA为会员提供的杂志，涵盖科学、教育、心理学实践等。该故事将于4月1日在线发布。您可以访问APA网站 APA.org/monitor 阅读它。这是我们制作的第二期特别节目，重点关注
breaking news in addition to our bi-weekly podcasts that air every other Wednesday. We want to know what you think about these new episodes and our regularly scheduled podcasts. Please share your comments and ideas with me. You can email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts such as APA Journal's dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes
突发新闻，此外还有我们每隔一个周三播出的双周播客。我们想知道您对这些新剧集和我们定期播出的播客有什么看法。请与我分享您的评论和想法。您可以给我发电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。那是 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，例如关于新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》（APA Journals Dialogue）和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》（Progress Notes）。
about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。